foreign
well Christina as I was Doom scrolling
on Instagram as I tend to do I saw this
post from ESPN pop-up and here's the big
headline a record 50.4 million U.S
adults are expected to bet a combined 16
billion dollars on this year's Super
Bowl
just take that in for a second
16 billion dollars 50 million Americans
that is a large percentage of the entire
population
now at first I went okay that's crazy
but then I went wait aren't these the
same people complaining that inflation
is too high and there's not enough money
at the end of the month and they're
living paycheck to paycheck and so that
was my post my reaction was Americans
inflation is killing us we're living
paycheck to paycheck out here also
Americans oh yeah bro I got 500 bucks on
the Chiefs
make it make sense that's all I'm asking
this just boggles my mind that people
are willing to spend their hard-earned
money and just throw it away at a sports
Casino for fun so here's the
juxtaposition Yahoo finance said that
half of Americans say their personal
financial situations are worse now than
they were a year ago which is more than
any time since the Great Depression and
Fox Business said amid High inflation
Rising interest rates credit card
balances have now increased to 931
billion dollars in the final quarter of
2022. this is insane the number of new
credit cards have uh opened have spiked
21.6 million dollars in the third
quarter I mean the levels of debt with
the levels of sports betting tell me
that bad things are happening out there
yeah that's very concerning it makes me
wonder is is it kind of like the
lipstick for men you know how like what
they say whenever there's a recession
like women buy more lipstick like sports
bet more I guess that's what they do to
to you know quell all the anxiety is
they just turn to sports and then they
go well my friends are better it's now
normal to bet on Sports there's a
thousand apps and yeah okay let's see if
Mahomes gets the touchdown in the you
know in the third quarter it just
doesn't make sense that's wild I thought
it was more of a niche I thought it was
like you know sports betting there's
probably two or three percent of people
but 50 million people every year it's
become legal in more and more States I
think it's like 33 States now allow
sports betting and here's the thing
they're seeing record profits it's like
the new crypto because it feels not as
dumb as crypto because it's something
that you enjoy that you know a lot about
but these bookies that are behind the
scenes they are going to win The House
Always always wins this is just like
Vegas except you get to do this from the
comfort of your freaking couch
and it's wild too because we've seen so
many studies and stats on kids and
teenagers getting into this where it's
like young kids I don't think they're
really supposed to but it's becoming a
huge thing in high schools where we're
worried about kids doing sports betting
which that just blows my mind and the
bankroll you need to even make any
amount of money in this is insane you
would need to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars to see any
meaningful return but what happens is
you throw 50 bucks you lose it you put
another 50 bucks in you might win it
back and so there's an addiction
happening especially with these young
people it's like the gateway drug to
gambling addiction and here's what's
crazy the number of expected Super Bowl
Bettors is up 61 percent from last
year's survey
and uh our start of state of personal
finance study uh found that in the last
three months 14 of people said they had
placed a legal Sports bet it begs the
question how many placed illegal Sports
bets we just don't know no one's gonna
admit that but 36 percent said they lost
money in 20 2022 sports betting and
that's equivalent to five percent of the
population having lost money on this
George what would you say that just
hurts my head a little bit thinking
through all the people who are
struggling with their finances and all
the people who feel like they're
drowning in credit card debt but they're
still betting what would you say to snap
people out of that well number one if
you are really struggling like truly
struggling now I'm hoping and praying
that the people that are sports betting
are out of debt with a fully funded
emergency fund and they're investing 15
and this is just fun money they're okay
blowing if that's you I am happy for you
the the record indicates that is not the
case and so if this is you and you're
going this is my last my last ditch
effort uh let me at least have some fun
I'm broke might as well at least have
some fun you're only going to get broker
and so we need to stop the bleeding and
go anywhere there's money leaks we need
to stop there are better ways to be
entertained and blow 50 bucks then on
the big game and onto squares and it's
just gotten out of control and so just
say no go to the party uh you know bring
a dip it costs you five bucks and enjoy
the Super Bowl that way but do not play
in this Sports Casino you will lose the
house always wins and there's a reason
why Vegas is doing so well and America
is so broke
it's a good word George oh my goodness
and we've covered you know sports
betting on multiple multiple areas
multiple shows uh Rachel Cruz show we
did a thing on sports betting if you
want to see me in a Brady Jersey you can
check that out hopefully he's retired
for the last time we just don't know we
don't to be determined oh well I enjoy
the big game do it on a budget and don't
be stupid
hope that hits